انه موسم التوجه الى الحقول
هنا في ضواحي مدينتكيفا في ولايه العصابه
شرقيه موريتانيا يتوافد 117 مزارعا الى
قطع ارضيه منحتها لهم الحكومه مؤقتا حيث
يتابعون تطورا نمو بذور وزعتها عليهم
وزرعوها مع بدايه موسم الزراعه المطريه من
بين الذره والفستق السوداني
وسينتظرون لاشهر موسم الحصاد لجني ثمارها
تبدا النتيجه
عندنا بوتر عنده الات نفخ السلطات تسعى
الى تطوير مهاراتهم عن طريق مرشدين
زراعيين من اجل زياده المساحه المزروعه
وتتوقع انتاجا وطنيا يغطي 47 في المئه من
الاحتياجات من الحبوب التقليديه
شريان الترابي
يعود تعود النبعه تطلع الثانيه حمايه
الحيوان
[موسيقى]
تقنيات حديثه علي الله عز وجل لنا لا ينتج
منه كميه كبيره يعود المساحه التي كبيره
وتعود الاليات اللي تتطلب العمل
في التحكم في المياه
ساهمت التساقطات المطريه الهامه هذا العام
في زياده حماس المزارعين من اجل رفع مستوى
المحاصيل لكن تنويع المنتوج الزراعي يظل
رهنا بتجاوز تحديات بينها الحصول على
الاليات المناسبه والاستفاده القصوى من
السدود لتوفير المياه
الجزيره من ضواحي المدينه